speaking of revolution
joy behar over on the view
just epitomized so much of the utterly
ignorant
arrogant
views of her side especially when
they're talking about guns she the left
is trying to grab guns i think they know
it's basically a lost cause but she
thinks she's identified the one
way in which republicans might turn
against the second amendment and that's
if those black people get guns here's
the thing once black people get guns in
this country the gun laws will change
trust me
that's what happened with the black
panther black people
trust me okay republicans are far more
racist than they care about the second
amendment now
this is obviously a very stupid
statement from joy behar but it's
especially stupid because she she's
speaking to a black woman here on the
panel on the view and just
moments earlier but maybe i don't know
two minutes earlier
the black woman on the panel blew up
joy's theory
all right i just say this real quick as
a gun owner there are people in this
country that genuinely own guns you
catch that
gadget hi i a black woman as a gun owner
and then she goes on and and talks about
how we don't need all of these guns and
she's trying to find this moderate
position on it but she just told joy
behar
yes i own a gun and then what does joy
behar do she says oh shut up black lady
hold on that you're getting in the way
of my narrative no black people they
don't have guns and once and those
republicans hate black people shh i said
stop talking black lady i'm trying stop
telling me about your actual experience
i'm trying to express my views about
your experience and black people yeah i
know i know there's a statistic says one
in four black americans already own guns
yeah forget about that for a second i'm
trying to make a point about how racist
you republicans are
speaking of the view there was another
radical just showed up to the view not
one of those ladies but the joe biden
education secretary the joe biden
education secretary shows up on the view
to address this question of how to
protect schools one of the whatever you
think about gun control whatever you
think about ar-15s whatever you think
about whatever we should all be able to
agree that if you want to protect
schools there are some basic measures
that will help
lock the doors i think is locking the
doors ideological is that is that a
partisan battle now just lock most of
the doors have an armed guard there
is that having an armed guard to stop
the bad guys that the i guess the cops
are ideological now
i guess they are partisan now
really shouldn't be
maybe let teachers who are law abiding
gun owners maybe let them carry their
guns you notice that the shooters always
attack
gun-free zones they always attack soft
targets so maybe harden up those targets
a little bit you won't get as much
shooting one of the ladies on the view
asks joe biden's education secretary
about this thought and
he doesn't like it
some republicans have proposed arming
teachers to stop these shootings my
mother is a teacher
in ohio the governor is preparing to
sign a bill that would lower the
training requirements for a teacher to
carry a gun in the classroom from 700
hours to 24 hours
in your view do you support teachers
carrying guns in the classroom
those are some of the
stupidest proposals i've heard
in all my time as an educator so that's
my answer to that listen we need to make
sure we're doing
sensible legislation making sure our
schoolhouses are safe as much as
possible but to say that we're going to
arm teachers to protect students what
happens when a teacher goes out on
maternity leave are we going to give the
substitute of the day a gun
what this shows sunny is that some
people are clueless when it comes to
what's happening in our schools
some people are in fact clueless that's
true i i think dr miguel cardona here
the secretary groomer of education
wearing his little progress pride
pin on his lapel i think he might be the
clueless one
because he doesn't even understand
the
the argument for arming teachers he
proved that at the end he said at the
top
this is a dumb idea it's the stupidest
idea i ever heard doesn't quite explain
why and then he a little bit later he
gets to he says what what happens when
you have a substitute teacher you're
going to give him a gun that's
the argument for arming teachers is not
that you require every teacher to have a
gun
the argument for arming teachers is that
you have some teachers with guns
and and by the way you don't know
necessarily which teachers have the guns
and so when an assailant or a would-be
assailant comes into the school
pretty much everyone he sees potentially
could be armed and when that's the case
people tend to be a little bit more
polite people tend to be a little more
cautious and reticent
if they go into a school and they know
for a fact no one is armed then they can
run them up they can do whatever they
want
but you don't the point is not to have
every single person they're packing you
know arm the third graders too the point
is to just have some guns out there and
you don't know who's got them and you
could turn the corner to wreak havoc and
then boom there's the gym coach boom
there's the history teacher and you just
you just
don't know
that's what joy behar was proving up
there when she made her stupid point
about about black gun ownership all
she's showing is that she truly has no
idea
what how one what black people think
about guns and two what conservatives
think
she thinks that if conservatives knew
that black people were getting legal
guns that they would turn on the second
amendment
many of you listening right now are
conservatives many of you listening
right now are black too is that
is that how you feel no of course not
but i give her points for sincerity i
think she probably sincerely believes
that and she's just completely mistaken
dr groomer here secretary groomer
probably sincerely believes that the
arguments that conservatives are
advancing are
are for arming all of the teachers
because he's got wind blowing in between
his ears and can't process what we're
actually saying he probably just doesn't
know and he can chalk that up to
ignorance and a lack of curiosity but
that is not the argument that we are
making yet again we see
something that social scientists have
shown again and again over the years
which is that conservatives understand
the libs
much much better than the libs
understand conservatives
by the way the the argument for arming
schools for putting guards at least at
schools was just proven correct
yesterday
there was a man outside of an alabama
elementary school
who was
demonstrating aggressive behavior
he was walking around he was yelling he
was trying to get into the school it was
unclear what was going on and they sc
this is just being reported by al.com a
school resource officer on site
responded talked with the man and called
for backup
then a second officer arrived an
altercation ensued and the suspect was
killed he was fatally shot
officials have not yet said if the man
was armed
doesn't necessarily matter if the man
was armed if the man was suggesting that
he might be armed
he's trying to break into an elementary
school he's demonstrating very
aggressive behavior
two weeks after a mass killing at an
elementary school
this is what's going to happen
who knows what would have happened
had that guard not been there
had there not been good guys with guns
on the site
one officer suffered minor injuries he
was taken to the hospital no kids were
harmed the kids may not not even have
known what was going on outside
but that's the stupidest idea i've ever
heard what you want you want to have
people with guns to protect people from
bad people with guns that was stupid how
stupid
how out of touch do you have to be
with not not just modern society but
with the basics of human nature and
self-defense
and incentives to make that kind of a
comment i'm so glad you liked that clip
now if you wouldn't mind ring smash like
click bang wang what about a bing bang
go to the michael knowles show get those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]